Excuse me, I've never been to a laundromat before.
I'm not sure what to do.
Okay, no problem.
What do you need to do?
Just regular washing?
Yes, I guess so.
I just have regular clothes here.
Okay, then it's pretty easy.
You'll need to change about five dollars into quarters.
Where can I do that?
There's a coin changer right over here.
Then what do I do?
You'll need to get a small box of detergent.
There is a vending machine that sells detergent next to the washing machines.
Okay.
So I guess I just put my clothes and the detergent in a washing machine.
Yup, it's as simple as that.
Let me know when you are done and I'll give you a hand with the dryers.
Thank you very much.